A user represents a person who has access to Burp Suite Enterprise Edition via the web
interface or a system that is accessed via one of the APIs.
You can create new users directly in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
Alternatively, you can use SSO or SCIM to configure your users.
You can assign users to groups.
This allows you to grant permissions to users which are relevant to their roles.
Log in to Burp Suite Enterprise Edition as an administrator.
From the team menu, select all users.
To filter the list of users, click the filter buttons.
Before creating new users, we recommend connecting your SMTP server.
This makes it easier to invite new users to Burp Suite Enterprise Edition, reset passwords
and so on.
To create a new user in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition, log in to the Burp Suite Enterprise Edition
as an administrator.
In the team menu, select Add a new user.
In the user credentials section, enter the details for the new user.
Under choose a login type, select Password.
To allow the user to login immediately, select Enabled.
Select the groups that you want the user to belong to.
When you've finished, scroll down and click Save.
The new user appears in the list of users.
If you have already connected your SMTP server, the user automatically receives an email invite
to complete the registration process and obtain their password.
If you haven't connected your SMTP server, you can copy the link when prompted and email
it to the user manually.
If you need to create a user to enable integration with other software, refer to Creating API Users.
You can edit most of the user details.
However, you can't change a user's login type.
To edit an existing user, log in to Burp Suite Enterprise.
Make sure you're an administrator.
From the team menu, select All Users.
Click the user in the list and edit their details.
When you've finished, scroll down and click Save.
If you have enabled SCIM integration, you need to manage any SCIM users and groups using your
identity provided administration console.
You can temporarily suspend the user.
You may want to do this if they are on extended leave, for example.
Ensure you're logged into Burp Suite Enterprise as an administrator.
From the team menu, select All Users.
Click the user in the list.
To temporarily suspend the user, deselect Enabled.
To delete a user, log in to Burp Suite Enterprise Edition, again as an administrator.
From the team menu, select All Users.
Find the user in the list.
In the right-hand column, click the Delete icon.
At the prompt, click Delete.